حول الفرص أه بين
إسرائيل والإمارات
التي تحدثت عنها تحديدًا عن
الفرص المتاحة
للفلسطينيين في القدس الشرقية ، هل يمكنك أن
تشرح بالضبط
ما تعتقد أنه قد يكون على الطاولة
جيدًا ، استمع جيدًا أه
في القدس نحن
أكبر مدينة  في الدولة التي تضم
أيضًا المدينة الأكثر تنوعًا في
البلاد ، نحن متشابهون جدًا مع دبي
حيث أنا الآن
من حيث التعددية الثقافية ، 37 من
سكاننا في
المدينة هم من
العرب والعرب الذين يتحدثون بشكل أكثر أهمية في
الوقت الحالي  كانت بلدية القدس في
حكومة إسرائيل
على مدى السنوات القليلة الماضية
تخطط
وتنفذ تطوير البنية التحتية
للقدس الشرقية
لتوفير المزيد من الفرص للأشخاص
هناك الذين يجلبون
ازدهار الدولة الناشئة
أيضًا إلى القدس الشرقية وأرى هذا على
أنه  جسر طبيعي جدًا
لدينا أشخاص يتحدثون اللغة العربية ولدينا
ثقافة مماثلة
وأعتقد أنها جسر عضوي طبيعي
لدينا الكثير من المبتكرين  في القدس ،
وصل الابتكار أخيرًا إلى
السكان العرب الشباب في
القدس وأعتقد أن القدس الشرقية يمكن
أن تكون في الواقع هي
المنطقة التي أعتقد أن القدس الشرقية
يمكن أن تكون في الواقع
مركزًا للشرق الأوسط